NOW ON "SUNDAY MORNING FUTURES."
♪
MARIA: AND FIRST THIS MORNING,
FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS
CONTINUES TO FIGHT THE POWER
GRABS, INEPTITUDE AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL RULINGS OF THIS
WHITE HOUSE.
EARLIER THIS WEEK HE CALLED THE
FLORIDA LEGISLATURE BACK FOR A
SPECIAL SESSION TO ADDRESS THE
FEDERAL VACCINE MANDATES TO
CREATE PROTECTIONS FOR
FLORIDIANS WHO RISK LOSING THEIR
JOBS.
HE IS ALSO LOOKING TO HELP
ALLEVIATE THE SUPPLY CHAIN LOG
JAMS IN CALIFORNIA BY OFFERING
COMPANIES INCENTIVE PACKAGES TO
REROUTE THEIR SHIPS TO FLORIDA’S
PORTS.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW IS THE
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA.
GOVERNOR, IT’S GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE
THIS MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
MARIA: TELL HE FIRST ABOUT THE
LOG JAMS THAT WE’RE SEEING IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE’VE GOT ABOUT 160 SHIPS
SITTING THERE IDLE, UNABLE TO
DROP OFF PRODUCTS, THAT’S WHY
WE’VE GOT EMPTY SHELVES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
WHAT CAN YOU DO IN FLORIDA?
>> WELL, MARIA, WE’RE REALLY
PROUD OF OUR SEAPORTS.
SINCE I’VE BEEN GOVERNOR, WE’VE
INVESTED ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS
INTO MODERNIZING THEM AND MAKING
THEM EVEN MORE EFFECTIVE, SO WE
HAVE CAPACITY.
SO IF THERE ARE SHIPS THAT ARE
IDLED OFF THE WEST COAST AND,
ACTUALLY, THERE’S SOME OFF
SAVANNAH ON THE EAST COAST AS
WELL, WE’VE ALREADY HAD SOME
FROM IS SAVANNAH BE REROUTED.
WE CAN ACCEPT THAT, WE HAVE HER
CAPACITY.
AND THEY MADE A BIG DEAL ABOUT
CALIFORNIA PORTS WOULD START
DOING 24/7.
WE ALWAYS DO 24/7 IN FLORIDA, SO
WE HAVE MULTIPLE OPTIONS.
EACH INDIVIDUAL PORT CAN OFFER
COMPANIES INCENTIVE PACKAGES TO
BE ABLE TO DO IT.
OBVIOUSLY, THAT’S A GOOD THING
FOR FLORIDA BECAUSE WE’RE
DRIVING HER ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
OUR STATE, AND WE’VE BEEN DOING
VERY WELL, BUT IT’S ALSO GOOD
FOR THE COUNTRY TO BE ABLE TO
ALLEVIATE THESE LOG JAMS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE SHORTAGES CONTINUE TO
PILE UP, AND ESPECIALLY AS WE
GET INTO THE CHRISTMAS SEASON,
THIS DRIVES INFLATION EVEN
HIGHER.
I MEAN, IT’S A HUGE PROBLEM, AND
SO FLORIDA CAN STEP UP AND HELP
BE A PARTIAL SOLUTION TO THIS
REALLY NATIONAL CRISIS.
WE WANT TO DO IT.
MARIA: SO TELL ME MORE ABOUT THE
ECONOMY IN FLORIDA.
YOU SAID THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
CREATING JOBS.
YOU KNOW, THERE WERE REPORTERS
MOCKING YOU OVER THE LAST SIX
MONTHS FOR YOUR STANCE ON
INSURING THERE WAS FREEDOM AND
LIBERTY FOR FLORIDIANS, AND YET
NOW WE TURN AROUND AND YOU SEE
WHAT’S HAPPENED IN FLORIDA WITH
JOB CREATION.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> SO IN SEPTEMBER THE NATION AS
A WHOLE REPORTED 195,000 NEW
JOBS.
FLORIDA, THE STATE NUMBERS CAME
OUT THIS PAST WEEK, FLORIDA
SHARED THAT WITH 84,900.
IF YOU LOOK AT AUGUST 2021 AND
LOOKED AT OUR HOTEL REVENUE
COMPARED TO AUGUST OF 2019,
PRE-COVID, WE WERE UP 11% OVER
THAT, THE NATION AS A WHOLE WAS
DOWN 5% COMPARED TO PRE-COVID.
SO WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PROTECT
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS, THOUSANDS OF
SMALL BUSINESSES, AND WE’VE
PROVIDED MORE AND MORE
OPPORTUNITY.
WE HAVE 400-500,000 JOB OPENINGS
RIGHT NOW IN FLORIDA.
YOU GO BACK WHEN COVID FIRST
STARTED, EVERYONE THOUGHT
BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH A
TOURISM-BASED ECONOMY THAT WE
WOULD BE HAVING MASSIVE PROBLEMS
FOR YEARS TO COME, AND WE WERE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROTECTED PEOPLE’S RIGHT TO WORK
AND BUSINESSES’ RIGHT TO
OPERATE, AND THE RESULT IS WE’VE
REALLY BEEN LEADING THE WAY NOW
IN TERMS OF THESE ECONOMIC
NUMBERS EVEN IN THE FACE OF A
LOT OF HOSTILE TRENDS COMING OUT
OF WASHINGTON D.C.
MARIA: YEAH.
AND IS WE HAVEN’T SEEN ANY OF
THOSE HOSTILE REPORTERS REPORT
ON ANY OF THE FACTS IN FLORIDA
THAT YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT.
LOOK, THE PRESIDENT IS STILL
TRYING TO, YOU KNOW, CUT DOWN
THE POWER OF GOVERNORS.
LAST WEEK HE SAID THAT HE WOULD
SEND THE NATIONAL GUARD IN THERE
TO HELP WITH THE SUPPLY LOG JAM,
AND THEN THE WHITE HOUSE HAD TO
WALK IT BACK.
SO I ASK YOU BECAUSE THE
NATIONAL GUARD IS THE YOU ARE
VIEW OF GOVERNORS -- PURVIEW OF
GOVERNORS.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYING
REQUESTING USE OF THE NATIONAL
GUARD AT THE STATE LEVEL IS
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF GOVERNORS,
AND WE ARE NOT ACTIVELY PURSUING
THE USE OF THE NATIONAL GUARD ON
A FEDERAL LEVEL AFTER HE SAID HE
WOULD.
WOULD YOU, GOVERNOR DeSANTIS,
CONSIDER THE NATIONAL GUARD?
>> WELL, WE HAVE THE LOGISTICAL
KNOW-HOW AND CAPACITY WITH OUR
PORTS OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN, YOU
CAN BRING IT, WE’LL HANDLE IT.
THERE WILL BE NO NEED TO DO THAT
IN FLORIDA BECAUSE WE’RE
MODERNIZED.
WE’RE READY TO GO.
IF YOU’RE GOING TO START TALKING
ABOUT NATIONAL GUARD, WHAT HE
SHOULD BE DOING IS SENDING THEM
TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER TO GET
THAT UNDER CONTROL, BECAUSE
THAT’S A CATASTROPHE MONTH AFTER
MONTH.
WE SEE 100-200,000 PEOPLE COMING
ILLEGALLY.
HE INHERITED A POLICY UNDER
DONALD TRUMP WHICH WAS
EFFECTIVE, AND NOW IT’S A TOTAL
DISASTER.
AND SO HE’S ALWAYS CRITICIZING
GOVERNORS, HE’S CRITICIZING
FLORIDA AND TEXAS, BUT THAT’S
HIS JOB TO SECURE OUR COUNTRY.
AND HE’S FAILED TO DO SO.
MARIA: MEANWHILE, THESE VACCINE
MANDATES ARE CLEARLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, AND NOW YOU’VE
GOT FIRST RESPONDERS QUITTING IN
DROVES.
WE’RE GOING TO SPEAK WITH ONE OF
THEM WHO JUST LOST HIS BENEFITS
LATER ON IN THE PROGRAM, A
FIREFIGHTER FROM SEATTLE.
BUT LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
MANDATES AND HOW THEY’RE CAUSING
HAVOC, BECAUSE THE HEALTH
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
ALREADY AT CRISIS LEVELS, AND
NOW NURSES ARE SAYING, LOOK, I
HAVE RELIGIOUS REASONS, I HAVE
OTHER REASONS THAT I DON’T WANT
TO BE FORCED TO TAKE THE SHOT,
SO THEY’RE WALKING OFF THE JOB.
MILITARY.
IF YOU GET DISCHARGED IN THE
MILITARY WITH A DISHONORABLE
DISCHARGE, IT’S ALMOST
EQUIVALENT TO BEING TREATED LIKE
A FELON.
YOU CAN’T WORK AGAIN.
POLICE UNIONS ARE RESISTING.
IN CHICAGO THERE WILL BE FEWER
POLICE ON THE STREETS, ALREADY A
SITUATION THAT HAS CRIME
SURGING.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING WITH REGARDS
TO THESE VACCINE MANDATES IN
FLORIDA, GOVERNOR?
>> WELL, FORTUNATELY, WE’VE BEEN
ABLE TO PUT -- FIGHT BACK VERY
EFFECTIVELY AGAINST MANDATES
IMPOSED BY, FOR EXAMPLE, LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AGAINST POLICE AND
FIRE.
MARIA, THESE PEOPLE WE’VE BEEN
HAILING AS HERO, THE NURSES
WE’VE SAID HAVE BEEN HEROES THIS
WHOLE TIME.
THEY’VE BEEN WORKING DAY IN AND
DAY OUT.
THEY COULDN’T DO THE THEIR JOB
ON ZOOM, THEY HAD TO BE THERE,
AND THEY DID IT WITH HONOR AND
INTEGRITY.
NOW YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
KICK THEM OUT OF THEIR JOB OVER
THIS SHOT?
WHICH IS BASICALLY A PERSONAL
DECISION.
AND YOU’RE RIGHT, WHAT BIDEN’S
DOING IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
HE DOES NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO DO THIS.
BUT WHAT IT WILL DO ON A
PRACTICAL LEVEL IN ADDITION TO
BEING UNCONSTITUTIONAL, IN
ADDITION TO TAKING AWAY PEOPLE’S
PERSONAL CHOICES, IS IT WILL
WREAK HAVOC IN THE ECONOMY
BECAUSE EVEN IF A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THESE FOLKS END UP
LOSING THEIR JOBS OR VOLUNTARILY
WALKING AWAY, YOU’RE GOING TO
HAVE HUGE DISRUPTION IN MEDICAL,
IN LOGISTICS, IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND SO IN FLORIDA OUR POLICY’S
VERY CLEAR, WE’RE GOING TO HAVE
A SPECIAL SESSION, AND WE’RE
GOING TO SAY NOBODY SHOULD LOSE
THEIR JOB BASED OFF THESE
INJECTIONS.
IT’S A CHOICE YOU CAN MAKE, BUT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE’RE
PROTECTING YOUR JOBS AND YOUR
LIVELIHOOD.
MARIA: YEAH, NOT ONLY THAT, BUT
IN A SITUATION WHERE THERE’S
CRIME SPIKE ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNION,
POLICE UNION IN CHICAGO IS
ESTIMATING THAT 3,200 CHICAGO
POLICE ARE DEFYING THE VACCINE,
AND THEY WILL BE OFF THE JOB,
THAT MEANS OFF THE STREETS.
WHAT IS THAT DOING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEIR
FEELINGS OF SAFETY?
IT’S VERY CONCERNING.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHERE THIS IS
GOING.
I MEAN, IS HE JUST TRYING TO
INSIST THAT THIS IS A LAW SO
THAT COMPANIES FOLLOW OR COULD
ACTUALLY BE ABDICATED AND
CONFIRMED TO BE CONSTITUTIONAL?
>> WELL, FIRST, I THINK IT’S
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT ON A
SCIENTIFIC BASIS MOST OF THOSE
FIRST RESPONDERS HAVE IS HAD
COVID AND RECOVERED, SO THEY
HAVE STRONG PROTECTION.
AND IS SO I THINK THAT
INFLUENCES THEIR DECISION ON A
LOT OF IN THAT THEY HAVE ALREADY
HAD IT AND RECOVERED.
SO THEY’RE MAKING NO
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR THAT.
THEY’RE STILL PRETEND THING LIKE
THAT DOESN’T EVEN EXIST, SO
THAT’S REALLY, REALLY TROUBLING
WHEN YOU SEE THAT.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU, MARIA, IN
FLORIDA NOT ONLY ARE WE GOING TO
WANT TO PROTECT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ALL THE JOBS,
WE’RE ACTUALLY ACTIVELY WORKING
TO RECRUIT OUT OF STATE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
NEEDS IN OUR POLICE AND
SHERIFFS’ DEPARTMENTS.
SO IN THE NEXT LEGISLATIVE
SESSION, I’M GOING TO HOPEFULLY
SIGN LEGISLATION THAT GIVES A
$5,000 BONUS TO ANY OUT OF STATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT RELOCATES
IN FLORIDA.
SO NY IF PD, MINNEAPOLIS,
SEATTLE, IF YOU’RE NOT BEING
TREATED WELL, WE’LL TREAT YOU
BETTER HERE.
YOU CAN FILL IMPORTANT NEEDS FOR
US, AND WE’LL COMPENSATE YOU AS
A RESULT.
MARIA: WELL, THERE’S A REASON
BUSINESSES AND HEDGE FUNDS ARE
MOVING TO FLORIDA AS WELL AS THE
DEMOCRATS ARE NEGOTIATING TAX
INCREASES.
NO STATE INCOME TAX THERE.
GOVERNOR, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR